i missed that last part
when i heard what calamari oh did you
miss that i didn't know he liked the
vikings yeah i don't know
not not that the vikings have been great
during his time
they were better than ass i i didn't
know that well they've at least been to
the nfc
championship let's see calamari was born
in 97. the vikings went in 98 right a
thousand 2009
2017. that's four okay cowboys have
zero done would none would none be
accurate none
none none nfc championship appearances
hell the team that
kyler murray plays for christopher has
been to the nfc championship twice
in kyle's lifetime including a super
bowl that they could have won
should have won would have won over the
pittsburgh steelers so
that that to me when i his willingness
to come out and say the cowboys were
always asked my first thought was well
no they weren't but then i realized this
guy was born in 1970
97 yes they were yeah no yes they were
it's amazing you just think about it and
you go man it really has been that long
since
you know they were i don't want to say
legit contenders because they went
through that little period right in like
2006
seven where they were pretty damn good
and we thought they were like a legit
super bowl contender there's no doubt
there's the dak prescott year
you know when tony romo got hurt and
they were the number one seed and aaron
rodgers came into town and did all that
but yeah these young kids don't know the
dallas cowboys the same way you and i do
at least that's for sure
i grew up in an era where wait i knew
about the cowboys because they were like
a dying dynasty of the 70s we're still
kind of hanging around in the 80s right
and then stunk for that little period of
time and man then the 90s
that was the greatest thing going i mean
the dallas cowboys
for a guy like me i mean it didn't get
any cooler guys like michael irvin and
emmitt smith and deon
sanders i mean they were all fun and
glitz and glamour
and lots of big plays but yeah the
younger generation has no clue of that
none you know for the longest time the
cowboys and cardinals did not have a
rivalry from the cowboys perspective it
was a rivalry from the cardinals
perspective and the cowboys have owned
that series 56-33
and one is the all-time mark but the
cardinals have won
five the last six five the last six
dating back to 2008
and they'll play again week 17 this year
in dallas oh paula murray by the way 7-0
in his lifetime playing at
a t stadium high school college
nfl so he loves the stadium
doesn't really right love the team and i
wish they played
earlier in the year i hope that we
remember what kyle murray had to say
when
week 17 rolls around
that's what made me
so entertained by it the fact that
a guy who plays quarterback for a team
that will play the cowboys this year
could play them pretty much
every year theoretically would be
willing to say that
it just blurts it out i thought it was i
thought it was great i wish more guys
would be that candid
well yeah i'm with you i mean hey he's
not like taking a personal shot at them
right now
he's just saying hey when i grew up
there was nothing to cheer for
and i mean that speaks loud or at least
louder when it's a kid from the state of
texas saying it
that's for sure that that maybe might
hurt a cowboys fan or the jones family
or somebody like that a little bit more
than if some kid from oklahoma or
some idiot like me from new jersey said
that uh so that's where it stings a
little bit no doubt about it but
yeah it'll be interesting to watch it's
cool i like the way kylie mary handles
himself
he's not afraid to say things give
little looks
little mannerisms things like that he's
got a good way about him
and i guess we can cross off the
possibility of kyler murray eventually
pulling double duty for the texas
rangers and the dallas cowboys
if and when he oh yeah here you go you
tried to start a little of that this
last week too i saw that oh
the door's still open he could still i'm
just talking yeah
i'm not starting anything i'm just
talking that's what kyler murray said
hey he made it clear he still wants to
play baseball and he'd like to play both
and he was a top 10 draft pick of the
oakland days
chris so yeah i know until he stops
talking about it or until he says
i will never play baseball and never
talk about baseball again
football is the rest of my professional
athletic life until he says that that
door's there
and he should at a minimum use it as
leverage with the cardinals
or at most actually go do it try to
engineer a situation where you can play
baseball
and then show up and play football as
the offseason program shrink
what's what's the point of hanging
around team facility
keep yourself in shape know your offense
study at night study on the road study
on the plane
i i think if anybody can do it calamari
could pull it off i used to think
there's no way a quarterback could do it
you can't be part-time in the nfl as a
quarterback i think if anyone can do a
caller murray campaign well he's a
phenomenal athlete and he can probably
do it i just don't know what
what like to what extent of a level are
we talking about that's the difference i
mean we're talking about a guy that's
awesome
he doesn't need baseball to leverage
anything he's one of the better
quarterbacks in football
i mean he's certainly in the top ten
yeah spoiler kyla murray's gonna be in
the chris sims top 10 quarterbacks all
right
for the uh top 40 coin countdown but
it's about maximization and what do you
want to do there
and like what always would scare me
because you know i i
i was pursued by people to always keep
pitching
when i was in college and playing
football at texas
i had teams you know wanted me to keep
pitching to keep my major league hopes
up and do those type of things
but the thing i came to is i just
couldn't take away the time of
preparation
for football and i always got into the
thing mike of like
man am i really gonna take a month off
and you know yeah you know
okay try to think about football a
little bit but i'm really here at a
baseball place doing that it's hard to
totally focus in on the football
and here's the last thing that always
kind of bothered me a little bit
is you know there is some mechanical
differences between throwing a baseball
to football too
and that's one thing as i started
patrick mahomes well well
yeah okay you don't know that not at a
pro level i bet you if he had to go play
baseball for four or five months and
then he came in the first day and
through football it wouldn't look
exactly like patrick mahomes at first
he'd have to get used to it there's a
little different way to throw a bigger
object as compared to the smaller
objects so i'm just throwing out stuff
that
crosses my mind as a guy you know who
loves to throw things and been around it
my whole life
i'm just trying to picture your big ass
e.t hand yeah holding a baseball yeah it
could throw a fire it gets swallowed up
in there it'd be like me trying to throw
a marble
yeah well it worked good i could get my
hands on those seams and throw a two
seam or a four scene we're pretty damn
good
why didn't you do it i don't know i ask
myself every day
i go
[Music]
i'm driving in i'm going damn i gotta go
talk to floria if i just would have
played baseball i wouldn't be having to
do this this
my life would be so much different so
yes wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute
so it's higher on the list of things
that would have gone well that you
wouldn't have to deal with me
above i'd still have my spleen uh
yeah well it's no no that's not you're
right i'd rather have the
queen and then yeah okay thank you okay
thank you that's the nicest thing you've
ever said to me yeah you just went out
i beat that yeah i i i am uh
less unimportant to you than your spleen
yes that's good to know
um all right uh that but that was a fun
little thing this weekend because
if you haven't noticed especially on
saturdays and sundays in june there
isn't a whole lot going on
so when kyle murray dropped something
like that on my plate
uh yeah i'm i'm not going to complain
about it we're going to have some fun
with
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports